[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera
cos'è il mito che rapporto ha con la
storia può ancora oggi il mito aiutarci
a comprendere e indurre le
trasformazioni in atto i grandi
cambiamenti che ci aspettano di cui
abbiamo ascoltato stasera verso un
qualcuno futuro migliore più
desiderabile come ritessere questo filo
del mito il mito noi tendiamo a pensarlo
come l'evocazione di fatti non
documentati storicamente ma che comunque
vengono dal passato
in realtà il mito ha un rapporto con la
storia perché il mito e una sorta di
favola vi racconto che però nel tempo ha
animato tanti protagonisti storici e li
ha spinti ad agire realmente nella
storia quindi il mito e anche nelle
troviamo traccia non solo nella
letteratura delle arti nell'iconografia
manieri troviamo traccia nei processi
storici che è riuscito a determinare io
mi riproporrò due miti e vi proporrò una
pratica che oggi come pratica artistica
tenta di tester lì in una narrazione che
ci aiuti a comprendere il presente è che
ci possa guidare in qualche modo come
una bussola verso un futuro un futuro
più auspicabile e non solo quel futuro
che a volte con paura e ansia tutti
sembra ci aspettiamo europa europa è una
bellissima principessa
passeggia sulle spiagge del libano in
asia è un certo punto vede un
meraviglioso toro toro bianco né
attratta è attratta ne ha desiderio gli
si avvicina lo corona con dei fiori e
alla fine ci sarà in groppa questo toro
e zero il quale parte per le acque del
mediterraneo e porta via europa dal suo
luogo di origine verso il suo destino ma
europa e anche è anche nel sogno della
mamma di serse una bellissima donna di
nuovo che anche una cavalla come una
cavalla è bellissima donna ea se
affiancate conducono il carro di serse
però europa non ci sta e ribelle si
imbizzarrisce e fa ribaltare il carlo
quindi europa è la speranza il desiderio
di libertà è il desiderio di affrontare
un viaggio verso un mondo migliore e il
desiderio di fuggire da un gioco da una
dalle guerre dai cambiamenti climatici
dai problemi che ci ossessionano che ci
rendono la vita impossibile e quindi
quello che ci tengo a vedere in europa è
proprio questa idea di un viaggio e
questo viaggio animato la nascita e le
diverse nasci dell'europa nella
mitologia l'odissea ma anche l'eneide e
più recentemente nella storia alla fine
dell'impero romano quando l'europa era
sfinita in rovina
l'intuizione di ricostruire europa
attraverso i cammini di pellegrinaggio
di tendere dei luoghi spirituali lungo i
quali rimettere in cammino le persone
disperse confuse senza lavoro e senza
ruolo in un viaggio che man mano ha
disegnato i luoghi dell'accoglienza i
luoghi della cura ma anche i luoghi
dell'incontro della conoscenza dello
scambio e ha prodotto le città e quindi
europa è una rete di percorsi di città
lungo dei percorsi che si svolgono e
sembrano disegnare il desiderio di
costruire uno spazio di libertà europa
non ha dei confini non ha mai avuto dei
confini non è neanche un continente è
piuttosto questo itinerario verso
qualcosa che avanza e questo itinerario
attraverso un cambiamento subito epocale
nella speranza di ricostituirsi e così è
anche nel settecento quando europa il
grand tour è il viaggio nelle leggi
europee verso l'italia verso la grecia
proprio a cercare il mito d'europa
proprio perché per capire se può il mito
d'europa ancora essere agito rivenuto
certo quest'itinerario non è solo un
iter ario di incontri di scambio d'amore
era garantito da una legge sacra fin dai
tempi antichi che si chiama in greco
xenia che vuol dire ospitalità e la
xenia garantiva la reciprocità fra che
ospitava e chi veniva ospitato in una
dimensione sacra e questa dimensione
sacra ha permesso il trasferimento di
conoscenze importanti come la
navigazione la conoscenza delle stelle
l'agricoltura la lingua stessa la stessa
città
l'idea di città però forse questa idea
di città era incompleta perché l'idea di
città greca è un'idea che si basa su un
ethnos un popolo
e qui vorrei iniziare invece con il mito
di roma che va più in là il mito di roma
da più la perché è una città che nasce
fondata da profughi è una città che
nasce per essere eterna è una città che
nasce per essere universale
questo è il mito di roma ma roma non è
che eterna universale perché sempre
splendente sempre agita da eserciti
fortissimi che ne garantiscono il
successo per l roma è universale perché
sa deperire perché sa rinascere dalle
proprie rovine roma e universale perché
mitologicamente a un alter ego col quale
è sacralmente intimamente connessa
questo alter ego si chiama lazio ma che
non è esattamente la regione
amministrativa del lazio di oggi ma
lazio il selvaggio lazio ma è ciò che
cresce si evolve nasce spontaneamente
latium dal latino latere vuol dire
nascosto per prima ha nascosto saturno e
forse per questo si chiama così perché
saturno cacciato da giove suo figlio dal
regno degli dei in grecia
approda nel lazio e giano che è il
guardiano di tutte le grandi cambiamenti
lo accoglie e saturno nel lazio dio del
tempo e della gestione delle stagioni
porta l'agricoltura il biondo grano
l'età dell'oro e di questo c'è traccia
di questa fondazione della città c'è
traccia anche virgilio se traccia il
virgilio quando virgilio ci racconta che
enea profugo troiano pronto ad unirsi e
latini chiede aiuto evandro pastore
greco ultimo retaggio di questa antica
storia di saturno e lo trova tra le
rovine sul palatino di una città ancora
da costruire
quindi roma sa rinascere dalle proprie
rovine le le proprie rovine solo questo
selvatico sono la riappropriazione degli
spazi dismessi e abbandonati quanto è
ancora oggi vero questo quanto è grande
roma quanti spazi abbandonati alla città
quante risorse soprattutto l'ultima
stagione di architetture di progetti
falliti
oggi sono l'ambiente per forme di vita
nascoste vegetale animale ma soprattutto
umana che proprio lì sperimentano forme
di convivenza di socialità di
innovazione sociale cosa cioè più di
innovativo a roma se non chi nella
grande eastin ita abita lo spazio
abbandonato questa roma questo è il
lazio grande nemico di questo mito di
roma e proprio della capacità di
nascondersi e l'evidenza è l'evidenza
della tela contemporaneità che vuole
avere tutto chiaro vuole avere tutto
subito che vuole mettere tutto sotto dei
riflettori che non ammette uno spazio
oscuro di meditazione di rigenerazione
di spontaneità
tutto deve essere progettato previsto ma
i nostri strumenti per progettare
prevedere non sembrano più utili invece
a cambiare a gestire i cambiamenti in
atto e quindi noi nella paura del
cambiamento cir inseriamo invece di
accoglierlo e di provare a condurlo
verso un futuro più desiderabile lo
subiamo ci nascondiamo nei nostri
recinti che siano la nostre case i
nostri stati nazione litighiamo tra di
noi rischiamo di fare la guerra con gli
altri rischiamo di per paura rendere
ancora più catastrofico il cambiamento
di quanto ci possa apparire in questo
senso noi abbiamo intrapreso un'azione
artisti la poetica che in qualche modo
mito poeti che tenta di reagire questi
due miti nel presente quindi da un poco
più di un mese ci siamo aggirati attorno
a quello che oggi potremmo dire è il
luogo selvatico di roma nel senso di
ospitare forme
nuove e di socialità e di vita che è il
quartiere esquilino e li abbiamo
sottoposto a tutti un fatto storico una
legge la costituzione antoniniana che il
212 dopo cristo caracalla dette
all'impero romano questa costituzione
finalmente è in piena conseguenza con la
storia romana che sapendo il ruolo del
selvatico e il ruolo del sapete che il
campidoglio è stato il colle sacro in
cui nel bosco selvatico venivano accolti
i profughi per fondare la città e
siccome questo bosco si trovava in una
cella
questo può bosco sacro si chiamava asilo
e questa parola ancora oggi segna la
possibilità stessa dell'ospitalità bene
caracalla questo non poteva non saperlo
non poteva non essere che gli agito dal
mito oltre che della necessità storica
finalmente di convenire con l'utopia che
tutti siamo cittadini del mondo e quindi
caracalla ha fatto questa costituzione
ha fatto questa legge noi l'abbiamo
presa l'abbiamo iscritta in mezzo alla
piazza con tante persone diverse su una
lastra di travertino l'abbiamo scritta
in caratteri latini i muri e poi abbiamo
iniziato a tradurre nel quartiere
esquilino di roma si parlano 140 lingue
uno dei quartieri al dove si parlano più
lingue al mondo noi siamo riusciti a
tradurla per ora almeno in una
settantina di lingue bene io penso che
a questo punto sarebbe importante anche
coinvolgere voi perché dopo averla
iscritta questa stele noi con una
struttura di giunchi che sembrava una
nave con delle corde appese l'abbiamo
trascinata perché diventando di più è
diventato più più amici e più insieme
una comunità l'abbiamo trasportata
attraverso roma abbiamo affrontato una
città in cui a volte fa paura di andare
in giro per quanta psicosi c'è per il
terrorismo i carrarmati vicino al
colosseo e siamo passati attraverso quei
carrarmati siamo saliti fin dal collo
del campidoglio e siamo andati nel foro
boario un luogo un antico luogo sacro
così in maniera simbolica e lì c'è il
tempio di eracle vicino al tempio di
hera chris una pietra
l'abbiamo infranta abbiamo infranta
perché quella che è stata storia oggi è
ancora un'utopia e le utopie davanti
alle realtà si infrangono e adesso
abbiamo dei frammenti questi frammenti
ne abbiamo iniziati a portare a segnare
una nuova geografia dell'uomo d'europa
il primo frammento è partito poco più di
tre settimane fa c'è stata una marcia di
solidarietà con i migranti
abbiamo attraversato il confine
militarizzata fa l'italia e la francia
con contanti persone cittadini italiani
e francesi
e allora abbiamo consegnato un frammento
il 7 luglio questo frammento arriverà
calais stiamo per portiere per palermo
abbiamo intenzione di attraversare la
sicilia la sicilia con i paesi vuoti
dove c'è stato 50 anni fa un terremoto e
sicuri che l'energia di tutti i profughi
e dispersi non possa che essere lo
strumento con cui rivitalizzare un
entroterra ormai privo di funzione di
ruolo spa erano completamente spopolato
e poi andremo a lesmo e poi andremo a
saluta invece a occidente al confine tra
il marocco e la spagna
questi sono gli itinerari di viaggio il
percorso è iniziato
ora stante questa nostra attitudine di
fare dell'arte una pratica di
coinvolgimento sociale e di
trasformazione sociale non posso
accontentarmi né possiamo accontentarci
si sono qui molti degli amici con cui
stiamo lavorando di avervi solo come un
pubblico quindi tenteremo di
coinvolgersi io lo leggerò prima in
italiano in modo che sia comprensibile e
che poi possiate convenire o meno se
leggere tutti insieme questo testo
ognuno di voi ce l'ha in una lingua
diversa magari anche una lingua non
capisce ma in fondo è proprio questo la
confusione è una condizione confusione
di stare insieme di fondersi e una
condizione di scelta iniziale di uscire
dalla chiarezza e di iniziare a guardare
al futuro se voi intanto la trovate io
la leggo in italiano intanto loro sono
arrivati
l'imperatore cesare marco aurelio severo
antonino gusto dice diamo a tutti i
viandanti che sono nel mondo la
cittadinanza romana e il diritto a
migrare ovunque vogliano per diritta via
e senza impedimento
eccetto coloro che visibilmente
congiurano contro l'umanità e la
comunanza del genere umano e ora
proviamo a leggerla tutti insieme
l'avete trovata
ci siamo manteniamo un ritmo
io vado con latino imperato cesare marco
aurelio severo
santoni nota augusto di ci davamo sogus
peregrini
i conti norme terrà roma
romana civitate chiusi g
con quel elisa signoretto itinere e cile
impedimento saprete rea
incontra umanità the bells società umani
genesi coniugare idea
grazie
[Applauso]